So when you know,
if you watch yourself,
you say,
well I had a particularly good day at
work and what does that mean?
Well,
it means that you lost your sense of
time,
right?
Because when you're having not a good
day at work,
it's like first it's one minute to three
and then it's
45 seconds to three and then it's 30
seconds.
That's what school was like.
For me,
it was like click.
So funny.
You know,
I went to,
I went to my daughter's school,
I used to get in trouble for talking all
the time,
surprise surprise when I was a kid and I
was bored stiff in school and so I would
misbehave upon occasion out of pure
boredom.
And about 21 years ago I went to my
daughter's school to sit for a class.
It was about an hour long and I was
sitting there and the teacher had all
the kids on the floor and was having
some of the kids read to the others.
And some of the kids who were reading
couldn't read at all.
And I had exactly the same experience I
was sitting there.
It was like being like being seven years
old again and I could see the clock
going,
tick,
and I thought,
you know,
if I was in this classroom for three
days,
I would misbehave,
fit 40 years old,
I would misbehave exactly like I did
when I was when I was six.
No.
Well,
that's no place to be right because
that's.
You don't want to be in a place that's
stultifying.
You don't want to be in a place where
there's no challenge.
You might even quit your job if there's
no challenge.
Say,
well that's a good job.
It gives you security and you think,
God,
I can't stand this.
It's eating away at my soul.
It's all security and no challenge.
So why do you want to challenge?
Because that's what you're built for.
That's what you're built for your built
to take on a maximal load,
right?
Because that's what strengthens you and
you need to be strong because life is
extraordinarily difficult and because
the evil king is always widdling away at
the structure of the state and you have
to be awake and sharp to stop that from
happening so that you don't become
corrupt and so that your family doesn't
become corrupt and so that your state
doesn't have to be come become corrupt.
You have to have your eyes open and your
which sharp and your words at the ready
and you have to be educated and you have
to know about your history and you know
how have to know how to think and you
have to know how to read and you have to
know how to speak and you have to know
how to aim and you have to be willing to
hoist the troubles of the world up on
your shoulders.
And what's so interesting about that?
So remarkable.
And this is something that's really
manifested itself to me as I've been
doing these public lectures.
I've been talking about responsibility
to people,
which doesn't seem to happen very often
anymore.
And the audiences are dead quiet.
And I lay out this idea that life is
tragedy tainted by malevolence,
and everyone says,
yeah,
well we already always suspected that no
one has ever said it quite so bluntly,
and it's quite a relief to hear that I'm
not the only person who has those
suspicions.
And then the second part of that is the
better part,
and it's the optimistic part,
which is despite the fact that life is a
tragedy tainted by malevolence at every
level of existence,
there's something about the human spirit
that can thrive under precisely those
conditions if we allow that to occur.
Because as difficult as life is and as
horrible as we are,
our capacity to deal with that
catastrophe and to transcend that
malevolent spirit is more powerful than
the that reality itself.
And that's the fundamental issue.
I think that's the fundamental issue of
the Judaeo Christian ethic with its
emphasis on the divinity of the
individual.
As catastrophic as life is and his
malevolent as people can be.
And that's malevolent beyond belief.
Fundamentally the person has in spirit
the nobility to set that right and to
defeat evil and that and that.
More than that and that the antidote to
the catastrophe of life and the
suffering of life and the tragedy of
life that can drive you down and destroy
you,
is to take on exactly that
responsibility and to say,
well,
there's plenty of work to be done and
isn't that terrible and there isn't
anything so bad that we can't make it
worse and certainly try very hard to do
so,
but I have it within me to decide that
I'm going to stand up against that.
I'm going to strive to make the world a
better place.
I'm going to strive to constrain the
malevolence that's in my own heart and
to set my family's straight and to work
to work despite my tragic lot,
for the betterment of anything,
of everything that's in front of me.
And the consequence of that,
the immediate consequences of that is
that when you make the decision to take
on all of that voluntarily,
which is to stand up straight,
by the way,
with your shoulders back,
to take on that,
all that on voluntarily.
As soon as you make that decision,
then all the catastrophe justifies
itself.
In the nobility of your striving,
and that's what it means to be an
individual thing.
Thank you.